tant sur des questions qui sont à des
questions d'actualité brûlante
on pense en particulier à la préparation
du futur projet de loi sur l'immigration
qui nous mobilisent comme vous savez et
qui va nous mobiliser
nous évoquerons ensuite la question qui
est ce matin l'objet d'une grande
actualité des la protection des
surveillants de prison avec le mouvement
qui se développe aujourd'hui nous
évoquerons parce que cela a fait l'objet
d'un flou a pas voir pas forcément très
artistique la part du gouvernement
les jours derniers la question des
impôts locaux nous enchaînerons sur une
étude de l'ufc eux qui pointe un certain
nombre de déséquilibres dans la conduite
de la politique économique et fiscale du
gouvernement français et enfin nous
aborderons la question de notre dame des
landes
puisque on nous annonce une décision
prochaine du gouvernement et du
président de la république donc pense
qu'il est bon à ce stade que nous
puissions rappeler un certain nombre de
choses et notamment les engagements qui
avaient été pris par les uns et par les
autres et puis bien évidemment nous
sommes ouverts et des heureux de pouvoir
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
aurez alors si on veut commencer dans un
premier temps je laisserais être tout de
suite après la parole à laurence sur les
questions d'immigration
nous voudrions simplement revenir pour
que la position des républicains soient
bien comprises sur le projet de loi en
préparation
d'abord il faut rester dans cette idée
que tant que le projet n'a pas été
discuté et présenté en conseil des
ministres il y as forcément une marge
pour une évolution de ce texte
et c'est bien dans ce cadre là que nous
entendons insisté sur un certain nombre
de points qui nous paraissent des points
fondamentaux
nous voudrions simplement dire la chose
suivante c'est que le sentiment qui est
celui des républicains c'est plus qu'un
sentiment c'est même une certitude au vu
des éléments qui nous ont été
communiqués
c'est que nous sommes dans un texte
essentiellement technique qui entend
encadrer les cons
dition d'examen des demandes d'asile à
ce titre là cette clarification
nous ne pouvons qu'applaudir dans la
mesure où il est nécessaire d'essayer
d'améliorer le dispositif actuel et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a amené natacha
bouchart qui comme maire de sa commune
est aux prises avec ces phénomènes
depuis tant d'années avec beaucoup
d'appuis sens de la part de la puissance
publique d'estimer que sur le plan des
avancées techniques qu'elle pouvait
parfaitement s'y rallier mais ce que
nous disons également et c'est pour nous
non moins fondamental c'est que nous ne
pouvons pas imaginer que ce texte qui
s'appelle asile et migration ne concerne
que l'asile et ne s'attaque pas non plus
aux conditions dans lesquelles la france
doit faire face aujourd'hui au défi
migratoire non seulement de la part de
ceux qui demandent l'asile
quelles qu'en soient les raisons et on
voit bien que pour les deux tiers ce
sont de fausses raisons puisque les deux
tiers sont déboutés de leurs prétentions
mais également l'immigration légale dont
nous souhaitons qu'elle soit demain
mieux encadrer qu'elles permettent de
définir des objectifs quantifiés
qu'elles permettent aussi de gros si je
devais le dire globalement de définir et
de maîtriser un volume global
d'immigration légale
or ce texte ce projet tel que nous
l'avons aujourd'hui n'en pipent mot et
c'est bien ce qui nous inquiète
donc nous serons force de proposition
nous l'avons vu dès le départ d'abord
nous avons des groupes parlementaires
qui vont se saisir de ce projet et qui
avec les experts qui les peuples
pourront s'exprimer clairement sur cette
question et défendre notre position mais
ce qui nous importe aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que les défis
migratoires ne soit pas limitée dans la
volonté de maîtrise uniquement aux
déboutés du droit d'asile dont nous
attendons bien
évidemment que les reconduites à la
frontière ça accélère notablement quand
on voit les chiffres pitoyable que la
france peut afficher en la matière nous
souhaitons également cela était déjà
défendue par notre groupe au sénat que
l'aide médicale d'état qui est un
véritable appel d'air à l'immigration
irrégulière soit réformée nous estimons
qu'il y à la une de la part du du
gouvernement une une contradiction
formelle entre d'un côté un discours qui
a d'ailleurs été relayée par le
président de la république consistant à
dire qu'il veut être beaucoup plus dur
en matière de maîtrise de l'immigration
régulière et de l'autre un budget de
l'aide médicale d'état qui a augmenté
dans la loi de finances de 2010 8 208
millions d'euros donc on voit bien que
cette contradiction est flagrante et
qu'il va bien falloir qu'on s'exprime là
dessus je rappelle que c'est françois
hollande à son arrivée au pouvoir en
2012 qui est revenu sur la réforme de
l'aide médicale d'état que nous avions
des portes et avec nicolas sarkozy et
qui avait permis de réduire notablement
le nombre de bénéficiaires la france et
c'est son honneur accueille les
demandeurs d'asile elle soigne quiconque
en a besoin mais il faut savoir ce qu'on
met dans le panier de soins et c'est là
notamment key tout l'enjeu
voilà ce que nous voulions précisé
excusez moi d'avoir été un petit peu
long sur ces enjeux d'immigration mais
comme ils vont nous occuper dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent il est
important que nous puissions ce matin
avec vous expliquer un petit peu le
discours de la méthode qui va être celle
des républicains merci gilles bonjour à
tous alors concernant le mouvement des
surveillants aujourd'hui nous nous
associons totalement à leur démarche
car il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui dans
nos prisons françaises sur 70 mille
prisonniers nous des comptons environ
500 prisonniers qu'ils le sont en lien
avec des entreprises terroristes et au
moins 1200 même le chiffre de 2000 est
avancé sur des prix le saunier
radicaliser donc il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui d'apporter des réponses
fortes au personnel pénitentiaire qui
sont amenés à gérer ces détenus qui sont
considérés évidemment comme très
dangereux une enquête va être menée pour
savoir ce qui s'est passé exactement
au sein de cet événement en particulier
néanmoins il faut une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui et nous avons vu
que le cri d'alarmé des policiers la
semaine dernière n'a pas été entendu ni
par le président de la république ni par
le premier ministre ni par le ministre
de l'intérieur nous souhaitons ardemment
que cette fois le cri d'alarmé des
gardiens de prison et du personnel
pénitentiaire soit entendu nous
souhaitons comme nous l'avons mis nous
l'avons dit la semaine dernière le
retour des peines planchers et
comprenait bien qu'évidemment le
personnel pénitentiaire fait partie de
ce que nous souhaitons protéger
avec cette réforme nous avons là une
raison de plus de notre patrie pour le
retour des peines planchers et nous nous
avons lancé la pétition la semaine
dernière qui a un vif succès et nous
souhaitons que ceci soit entendue et que
le premier ministre revienne sur ses
propos et revoit les choses sur ce sujet
merci laurence troisième pointe sous
sections mettre en lumière ce matin
c'est la question de la fiscalité locale
nous y sommes d'autant plus attachés que
comme vous le savez les républicains
sont le premier parti de france par le
nombre d'élus locaux et que par
conséquent très attaché aux thématiques
du terrain et vous avez aussi un élu
local devant vous qui vous parle en ce
moment nous avons aussi ce souci de
véritablement porté à la connaissance
des enjeux nationaux les problématiques
locales
tout est parti mais à mes yeux d'un très
bon sentiment qui était celui d'hier
nous allons supprimer un impôt
c'est ce que monsieur macron avait
annoncé pendant sa campagne électorale
il n'a pas choisi de supprimer un impôt
d'état bizarrement il a choisi de
supprimer un impôt des autres c'est à
dire un impôt des collectivités c'était
une première
première approche qui nous a semblé
singulière mais surtout nous étions un
certain nombre a parfaitement savoir qu'
on ne supprime pas un impôt comme ça et
que lorsque de surcroît on s'est engagé
auprès des collectivités à les
accompagner dans cette suppression
pour qu'elle ne perde pas trop d'argent
du moins dans un premier temps et c'est
bien la crainte de l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales il fallait
bien trouver un moyen de financement
on a vu qu' il ya eu une grande
agitation la semaine dernière au sein du
gouvernement sur ces questions
des déclarations contradictoires avec
cette certitude qu'il faudra de toute
façon asseoir un nouveau prélèvement
si l'on veut du moins que les
collectivités puissent continuer de
faire tourner leurs services publics
locaux
ou alors qu'on nous dise qu'il faut
supprimer les services publics locaux
mais ça n'est pas ce que j'ai cru
entendre donc ce que nous voulons
simplement souligner c'est que si l'on
veut durablement baisser les impôts il
s'agit pas de faire des déclarations à
l'emporte-pièce devant le congrès des
maires il faut baisser la dépense
publique
il faut se donner les moyens d'avoir une
réduction sensible des prélèvements
obligatoires je vous rappelle que la
france en europe reste la championne de
la dépense publique
le budget 2010 8 augmentation par
rapport au budget 2010 est donc il n'y a
pas on ne change pas de ligne en la
matière et qu'elle est également la
championne des prélèvements obligatoires
donc il ne peut pas y avoir un débat
serein sur cette baisse de la fiscalité
locale
s'il n'y a pas un débat fermé des
engagements pris par le gouvernement sur
la réduction de la dépense de l'état
car les collectivités en elle-même qui
je le rappelle sont loin d'être les
premières responsables de l'endettement
public ne saurait être une variable
d'ajustement là où l'état lui même a des
devoir or il nous semble que le
gouvernement tourne le dos à ses devoirs
et préfère en faire porter la charge sur
les autres toujours sur ce sujet
économique nous déplorons effectivement
que malgré les annonces qui sont faites
la politique prévue pour 2018 est une
peau d'une politique d'augmentation des
impôts que plus 4,5 milliards de hausses
d'impôts mais surtout ce sont les
classes moyennes qui vont être les
grandes victimes de la politique
économique des manuels macron nous le
déplorons parce que au-delà
de la hausse de la csg bien sûr qu'il va
toucher 8 millions de retraités
nous avons aussi les grands ces deux
classes moyennes qui chaque jour vont
subir les augmentations et la diminution
du pouvoir d'achat notamment avec la
hausse des carburants
donc nous demandons à ce qu'il y ait
vraiment des mesures qui soient prises
pour que les classes moyennes ne soit
pas toujours les grandes victimes de
cette politique économique qui ne
bénéficient comme le disent de nombreux
rapports et notamment encore ce matin
celui de la fcpe à une petite catégorie
de la population qui ne doit pas
toujours être la même merci enfin nous
voudrions conclure notre propos
liminaire avant bien évidemment de de
répondre à toutes vos questions sur le
dossier de notre dame des landes avec un
mot très brèves de notre part nous
sommes attachés au respect des
engagements qui ont été pris il ya des
consultations populaires qui ont été
menées avec des résultats qui laissait
peu de doute sur le choix de la
population concernée nous voudrions
simplement aussi rappelé ce matin que le
président de la république lui même
pendant la campagne électorale avait
pris l'engagement de respecter la
consultation populaire et le référendum
donc nous rappelons simplement le
président république au respect des
engagements qu'il a lui-même pris alors
on a bien vu que ce dossier était de
plus en plus embarrassant pour lui mais
il y a aussi le respect de la parole
donnée c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
renforce et qu'on protège de l'autorité
de l'état
voilà mesdames messieurs ce que nous
voulions porter à votre connaissance en
préambule et nous sommes maintenant à
votre disposition pour toutes les
questions que vous pourriez avoir
alors j'ai fait ce matin dans ses voeux
annonce qui prend un petit peu de recul
qui ne reprendra pas sa cotisation
partie en 2018 en fait c'est un petit
peu comme dominique bussereau ce que
vous n'avez pas peur que l'ale plus à
gauche du parti vraiment s'éloigne alors
vous avez raison de rapprocher la
position qu alain juppé a exprimé ce
matin de celle que 2010 roa présenté
hier dans la presse et en particulier
dans le jdd ce qui nous paraît important
dans le grand débat qui va se lancer
prochainement au sujet des européennes
puisque c'est là dessus que les
questions particulier les deux
personnalités que vous venez de citer se
sont posés c'est que chacun y prenne sa
part et nous souhaitons contraire choses
soient bien claires que l'ensemble des
personnalités qui veulent peser sur la
ligne des républicains puissent rester
dans nos instances autant qu'elle le
souhaite parce que la porte est
évidemment grande ouverte pour pouvoir
peser sur les débats et exprimer leur
point de vue et peut-être que d'ailleurs
si ces personnalités éminentes de notre
parti répondent à cet appel
on se rendra compte que les lignes ne
sont pas si éloignées que peut-être elle
le craignent un grand débat va s'engager
au sein des républicains qui fera
d'ailleurs laurent wauquiez l'a dit hier
l'objet d'un conseil national spécifique
deuxième conseil national des
républicains le premier aura lieu comme
vous le savez le 27 janvier le deuxième
conseil national sera consacrée aux
questions européennes
donc c'est un enjeu qui nous motive
énormément
nous sommes au sein d'un parti pro
européen
cette ligne n'est absolument pas remise
en question mais nous avons un chemin à
trouver à tracer je pense que et nous
pensons que c'est une attente de nos
concitoyens entre d'un côté des partis
qui sont europhobe très concrètement et
qui ne s'en cache pas que ce soit les
insoumis où le front national ou quelle
que soit l'appellation cette
organisation dans l'avenir de madame le
pen et des formations qui au contraire
nous paraissent être beaucoup trop béate
par rapport à une situation qui est
insatisfaisante sur le plan du
fonctionnement institutionnel de
l'europe
donc notre position guillaume larrivé
l'avait défini ainsi il ya peu de temps
c'est l'euroréalisme et ça nous va bien
je pense que dans ce chemin dominique
bussereau alain juppé et tant d'autres
ont leur place
donc nous les engageons ont
véritablement à participer à ce débat le
débat sera lancé par laurent wauquiez et
nous souhaitons que tous ceux et celles
qui veulent y prendre part
puisse avoir un une voix à faire
entendre en tout cas nous leur donnerons
la possibilité de le faire tout de même
plus spécifiquement concernant alain
juppé c'était l'un des fondateurs de
l'ump c'est une voix forte au sein du
parti
comment vous réagissez précisément à son
départ est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque
de rabougrissement du parti comme
certains le disent depuis longtemps
vous savez on à moi j'ai pas entendu le
mot de départ de la part d'alain juppé
alain juppé a dit qu'il prenait du recul
ce qui est quand même un peu différent
le départ il a été acté pour xavier
bertrand par exemple qui a dit je part
des républicains
ni dominique bussereau ni alain juppé
non dit qu'il partait des républicains
et nous ne le souhaitons absolument pas
il souhaite prendre du retrait et voir
un peu comment les choses peuvent se
passer demain donc nous nous leur disons
dans ce dialogue respectueux que nous
avons vis-à-vis de ces deux
personnalités de notre mouvement nous
leur disons venez au contraire
participer à ce débat parce que c'est la
seule manière de faire entendre votre
voix
il n'y a pas une ligne qui soit d'ores
et déjà arrêtée sur la façon dont nous
allons aborder l'échéance européenne en
tout cas il ya quelque chose à
construire et nous avons besoin de tous
pour construire donc ça nous effraie pas
et nous estimons en tout cas que les
conditions même du débat qui va
s'engager permettra à ces personnalités
de se prononcer et nous en tiendrons
compte
alors moi j'entends dans les vois je
redis ce que j'ai entendu et lu comme
vous et je n'ai pas entendu que ces
personnalités qui tu es les républicains
mais prenez du retrait notamment en ne
payant plus leurs cotisations c'est
quelque chose de complètement différent
c'est pourquoi je mettais en parallèle
les deux démarches
la démarche de xavier bertrand qui est
une démarche de rupture que nous avons
regretté nous l'avons déjà dit quels que
soient les steam que nous portions à
xavier bertrand est une démarche qui est
une démarche de retrait le retrait ça
veut dire qu'on est prêt à abandonner
revenir dans le jeu sinon part je n'ai
pas entendu ça de la part des deux
personnalités donc nous souhaitons
qu'elle revienne le plus rapidement
possible dans ce jeu
à savoir si vous pensez quelque chose du
nouveau média qui va s'ouvrir ce soir
qui va démarrer ce soir le média sur
internet de l'extrême gauche et des
écologistes et du parti communiste c'est
nous sommes pour la liberté d'expression
donc c'est un moyen pour ces partis de
s'exprimer et nous verrons bien moyen
peut-être tourner mais nous verrons bien
comment c'est aussi évolué dans le temps
je pense que ce n'est pas dans notre
fonction de juger les journalistes quand
on est pour la liberté la liberté
d'expression au juge pas le
positionnement politique des
journalistes et on souhaite que
l'information soit traité de manière
équitable et nous n'en doutons pas alors
effectivement on peut imaginer où enfin
on constate que emmanuel macron un
traitement médiatique plutôt favorable
depuis quelques mois mais par ailleurs
nous espérons que nous soyons entendus
avec autant de bienveillance dans les
semaines et les mois à venir dans nos
actions au sein des républicains et dans
les actions de notre président laurent
wauquiez on est peut-être moins effrayés
par la création d'un nouveau média pour
les accusations qui peuvent être portées
contre la presse et qui ne sont pas de
notre fait les choses soient bien
claires vous avez votre métier à
accomplir et ce n'est pas à nous d'en
juger
au contraire c'est à nous de vous
solliciter aussi ce que c'est très bien
faire le président de la république et
même s'ils contrôlent abondamment
l'expression qu'il porte
mais nous sommes beaucoup moins inquiété
par cela que par le projet de loi sur
les faits que news
car quand on a vu ce week-end des fatwa
lancée par des proches des manuels
macron sur twitter en particulier contre
des comptes qui n'avaient pas leur
agrément parce qu'ils étaient un petit
peu distant vis-à-vis de certains
aspects de la politique de monsieur
macron on est particulièrement inquiète
donc notre inquiétude c'est pas que la
presse soir libre et pluraliste
ça c'est de la garantie de la démocratie
notre inquiétude c'est que le pouvoir
d'état contrôler l'information
en y mettant des conditions et en y
instaurant des mesures qui ne seraient
pas favorables à la liberté
merci est ce que il ya d'autres
questions tout bon pour vous parfait
merci beaucoup et à la semaine prochaine